so the development of speaking and  listening requires interactions with  somebody else  so that has to be done in classroom  because there are not so many Japanese  people on campus at MIT so classroom  activities really focus on the  development of listening and speaking  whereas reading and writing students can  do them like outside class and then in  particular our textbook has so called  workbook and then they can do writing  practice by themselves in fact we do we  provide assignment and so that they can  just you know practice writing at home  for reading we have our textbook has  reading section for each lesson and we  conduct we provide reading session one  day for each lesson in class